I have a few questions. Can I go to the dentist and get treatment health delete? Is it dangerous? I know I have
cavities and possibly root canals needed. So first of all, I wouldn't get any root canals,
personally. You know, it's hard to do that, whether it's a front tooth or something like that. But
there's just dangers in getting root canals. I think I have some articles on the blog post
and you can certainly Google lots of dangers in root canals articles out there by good biological
dentists. If a person, if you're fairly healthy, you're not like super, super sick with your cancer,
certainly you should go to the dentist and you should get your teeth cared for. You should go
try your best to go to a biological dentist who will not even recommend root canals them. So
find a biological dentist in your area would be my first choice because you want to get proper
dentistry, not just that, not just regular dentistry. Can I take soures off leaves to boil to make tea?
I don't know the answer to that. Honestly, I don't know. I've not ever done that. I've not had
anybody do that. Not anybody tell me that they were doing that. So I do not know the answer to that.
It's really good at getting rid of cancer. Yeah, I don't, I wish I'll do some investigation
on that, but I don't know. Can I, yeah, or is this pushing it for me? No, Yams has a very low glycemic
index, so you'd be fine eating tea. That would be fine. That would be a good source of some calories.